hey everybody welcome back to the
stronger by science podcast my name is
Eric Trexler I'm going to be your one
and only host for today's episode and
today's episode is going to talk a lot
about appetite now if you listen to this
podcast you're probably pretty familiar
with a lot of Fitness related uh content
and research and things like that uh
appetite is something that comes up in a
variety of different contexts in Fitness
so if you are cutting if you're doing a
weight loss phase a lot of times we talk
about strategies to manage hunger if you
are bulking up or trying to gain weight
a lot of times we talk about strategies
for navigating or circumventing a
suppressed appetite so no matter what
your Fitness goal is there are a lot of
applications where appetite becomes a
very pertinent consideration so in
today's episode I want to talk about
some of the key strategies that I've
personally utilized both for myself and
for my clients when it comes to
navigating appetite management
now it's still January as I'm recording
this and around this time of year a lot
of people have goals pertaining to
weight loss or fat loss or body
recomposition so for that reason in this
episode I'm going to talk a lot about
appetite but specifically as it pertains
to managing hunger when we're on a low
calorie diet or when we're trying to
maintain a relatively low body fat level
So Hunger will be the primary focus of
this episode strategies to manage and
navigate hunger but I'm also going to
briefly address bulking at the end of
this episode as well so I'm going to
talk about strategies that help you
navigate a bulking phase or a weight
gain phase when your appetite is really
suppressed so we're going to cover both
of those but before I get into it I want
to give a brief update about this
totally illegal strike that's going on
by the stronger by science podcast
co-host Union so if you've been watching
the last few weeks you know that they've
been making a ton of outrageous demands
most recently they asked for me to
purchase them a private jet and to
establish a fund that would cover the
operating expenses for that jet I've
made some pretty big steps toward both
of those particular requests moved a lot
of money around to make a lot of things
happen very very close to finalizing
some of the details there but now the
union has put another outlandish request
on my desk I think they were watching a
documentary or something maybe watch too
many episodes of the local news
apparently they got wind of uh you know
some new carbon taxes that might be
coming in the future some other
legislative regulations that are trying
to curb private Aviation so at this
point the union is requesting that I
secure preemptive exemptions to make
sure that they're not going to be
impacted by any future carbon taxes or
any future regulations that are aimed at
limiting private Aviation now if you've
been listening to the show for years now
our podcast does have a pretty long
history of influencing uh state and
federal policy we've made a lot of
things happen in the past couple years
so I'm working on this but it is
probably going to be a slow process
um you know I do have some contacts to
lean on but it'll take some time and
it's really hard to get exemptions for
rules that don't exist yet it's much
easier to get exemptions for rules that
are already on the book so I will
provide updates as they come in but for
now I'm doing my absolute best and I
just want to reiterate that this strike
is totally illegal and totally immoral
uh now before I get into the appetite
stuff here uh just a couple reminders if
you like the show there are many ways
you could support it you could like rate
or subscribe wherever you access the
show you can join our newsletter at
Stronger by science.com newsletter you
can check out our virtual one-on-one
coaching program at
strongerbyscience.com coaching you could
use our discount code at
bulksupplements.com the code is SBS pod
it gets you five percent off of your
order you can check out the mass
research review and you could also check
out macro factor which is the excellent
Diet app that Greg and I co-developed
along with a very talented team of
colleagues so macro factor is the diet
app you can find it on the app stores
and there is a free trial so you can
take it for a spin and see if you like
it
alright so now I'm going to Dive Right
In we're going to be talking here about
practical strategies for managing hunger
so to set the context imagine that you
are in a weight loss phase you're on a
calorie restricted diet or you're trying
to maintain weight loss after
successfully losing a bunch of weight so
you're still on a calorie restricted
diet and usually in these circumstances
hunger is going to be a noteworthy
challenge that that needs to be
addressed in some way so I'm going to
talk about a number of different
strategies very practical strategies for
managing hunger and the first one is an
interesting one because it kind of
involves doing nothing at all but in a
very productive way so the first one is
something that you've heard about if you
listen to a previous episode where I
talked about mindful eating I talked
about some of the mechanisms by which
mindful eating could potentially make a
weight loss diet a little bit easier or
a little bit more tolerable one of those
mechanisms is that if you incorporate
mindful eating it's very likely that you
will be adopting what we call an
acceptance-based approach to Weight
Management so I want to talk about this
acceptance based approach specifically
as it pertains to hunger and I'm going
to link a research paper in the show
notes if you'd like some more
information but if we apply this to
hunger what that means is when hunger
arises
we are not trying to uh reject the fact
that it's there we're not trying to uh
convince ourselves that it doesn't exist
we're not trying to suppress it we're
not trying to fix it uh even when hunger
isn't yet present we're not trying to
avoid it at all costs you know a lot of
people when they get into dieting and
they get on a calorie restricted diet
they try really hard to avoid hunger uh
to the extent that it's possible you
know they really fret over the
possibility that hunger may arise and
when it does arise they try to reject it
suppress it or fix it in some way and
what what we want to do if we adopt an
acceptance based strategy is really
reframe the way that we experience
hunger uh so when I talk about this
because there is such a clear parallel
with mindful eating I am going to lean
on a bit of a Buddhist analogy for this
so if you have absolutely no patience
for a Buddhist analogy that's all about
perspective if you're here for the
really nitty-gritty academic science you
can skip ahead a little bit but I do
think this is a helpful perspective to
consider when it comes to an
acceptance-based approach to hunger
management or Weight Management more
generally so the Buddhist analogy
is originally about how to deal with
strong emotions or or very strong
Sensations that we experience and in the
analogy you imagine that you're sitting
on the bank of a river and there are
leaves that are just kind of floating by
on the surface of the river
and in this analogy or in this metaphor
each of these leaves that's floating by
on the surface of the river is a thought
a feeling an emotion or a sensation and
we can imagine hunger is one of those
leaves that that is floating by uh now
like I said these leaves are they
represent our thoughts our feelings our
emotions our Sensations most importantly
these leaves are not part of us they are
external to us and they are simply
passing by they are temporary and they
are external so what that means is if
you want as you're sitting on the bank
of this River you can pick one up and
engage with it if you like or you can
let it pass by without engaging with it
at a high level and what that means is
you know letting it pass by is very
different from trying to destroy it or
reject it or suppress it or pretend it
doesn't exist letting something pass by
is very different from doing any of the
those things so when we use this analogy
this is not letting a leaf pass by in
this metaphor is not an act of asserting
mental control we are not saying I'm
going to wrestle with this thing and
overcome it and overpower it and
suppress it that's absolutely not what
we're talking about here what we're
talking about is not asserting mental
control what we're talking about is an
action of Letting Go you know to let
something float by is a passive action
to pick it up and interact with it or
try to change it that is a a decision to
to engage with it in that way now if we
feel like we have no choice you know if
we feel like we are unable to avoid
picking up this metaphorical leaf and
interacting with it what that probably
means whether we're talking about a
thought an emotion a sensation is that
we need to do a little bit of work to
try to re-center ourselves and calm our
mind a little bit and get back into the
dry driver's seat of our mind you know
and the way that our mind is interacting
with the thoughts and the emotions and
the and the sensations that are passing
by and so this is where where
mindfulness practices come into play
um you know a lot of times you know I I
do sitting meditation on a regular basis
and and sometimes people find the
concept to be very foreign and very
difficult to understand because it a lot
of times people think what does it mean
to sit there and have literally no
thoughts and I think of setting
meditation very differently I think of
it as the practice of pulling myself out
of this raging River where I'm getting
tossed around by the water and
interacting with these leaves uh without
any intentional decision to do so I'm
trying to pull myself out of this River
and sit on the bank and watch the river
with calmness and with solidity so it's
the act of not getting tossed around and
chasing every thought and emotion and
feeling like we have to either work on
it or change it or suppress it it's the
act of removing yourself from that
turbulent water of the river sitting on
the bank and understanding that you're
able to remove yourself uh create some
distance from these thoughts and
feelings and perceptions and Sensations
and you can make the choice to interact
with them or to reframe them as you see
fit so what that means is when we see
Hunger arising
we don't want to pretend it's not there
you know we want to say hey hunger I see
you I know that you're there and I'm
here with you I'm not trying to reject
the idea that you exist I'm not trying
to a force you to be something else
again you being the hunger in this
scenario
but you hunger are separate from me you
you are not me you are separate from my
emotional state my worries my actions
and and because you're separate from
those things you are not able to control
them you know hunger is not able to just
show up and completely change my
emotional state uh force me to worry and
stress over it change my actions in
terms of my dietary choices this hunger
is separate from me and this hunger is
not permanent and so what that means is
just like the leaf on the river it will
pass eventually I don't need to fix
anything I don't need to do anything I
don't need to suppress anything what I
really need to do is re-center myself
pull myself out of that raging River sit
on the bank and watch those leaves
passing by and remind myself that I have
the autonomy to choose which of these
leaves I'm going to interact with so
when hunger is arising we think of it as
a leaf that's passing by if we want to
pick it up and explore it and interact
with it that's something we can do but
we have the choice to let it pass by if
we see fit so it's not just about Hunger
when we talk about acceptance-based
approaches to Weight Management this
could apply to something like food
cravings as well but I know that I
talked briefly about this concept in the
episode about mindful eating
and I wanted to take a moment to
elaborate on it a little bit more uh
because I think it's uh the type of
concept that can be very difficult to
understand without examples without
metaphors without analogies but once you
start to get a sense of what we're
talking about here of entering a dieting
phase a weight loss phase and accepting
on the front end
I know that I'm going to be interacting
with Hunger at some point with food
cravings at some point these things are
going to arise and they're going to pass
and then they're going to arise again
and they're going to pass again and what
we want to do is accept that on the
front end we want to accept the fact
that these challenges are going to be
part of the process and there's nothing
wrong with that we do not need to craft
a perfect plan that is going to allow us
to never run into hunger or to never
experience a craving what we need to do
is accept that those will be part of the
the process they will be part of the
journey but we need to make sure that
we're taking care of our our mental
perspective of how we interact with
those things as they arise if we can
interact with them in a in a way that
Embraces acceptance what we'll find is a
lot of very uh a very a lot of very
productive and proactive perspectives
when it comes to hungering Cravings if
we don't adequate quickly prepare
ourselves for that and we panic when
these things arise and we view it as a
bad thing then when hunger arises when
Cravings arise we might find ourselves
in a position where it really takes over
our mental state we start to panic about
it we worry about it we become miserable
we suffer from it because we are unable
to accept it and sometimes it can even
dictate the way we approach our diet we
may deviate from our diet because we
believe that this hunger or this craving
truly has taken control and our only
option then is to appease it by
deviating from the diet and ultimately
accommodating whatever this uh transient
experience is dictating that we do so
acceptance based approaches I know that
they it really seems way outside the box
when it comes to typical Fitness
industry dieting advice the only reason
I bring it up and belabor the point and
dive deep into these men metaphors and
analogies is because I genuinely do
believe that this is probably the most
important strategy for managing hunger
uh
when we are dieting or when we are
trying to restrict calories and the
reason I kind of pause there and get
caught up in my languages because it is
a bit of an oxymoron this particular
strategy is an approach to managing
hunger in which we liberate ourselves
from the obligation of managing hunger
so it I know it it kind of sounds
um a bit paradoxical there
or a bit oxymoronic but in some ways the
best way to manage hunger is to let
yourself remember that you actually
don't really have to manage it all that
much you can let it pass by and reframe
it in a way that's constructive to you
and again I just want to reiterate to
reframe it in a constructive way is not
to reject the fact that it exists or to
reject the fact that it is unpleasant
when it arises hunger is not a pleasant
sensation so I'm not saying that uh the
suffering induced from Hunger is all in
your head and you should simply opt out
of it but what I am saying is there's
probably a way to reframe your
perspective toward hunger that will
remove a lot of the power that hunger
can have over people when they're
dieting so I really would encourage
people to dig into this concept very
deeply and to embrace it with an open
mind because the research would indicate
it's a very effective uh perspective to
bring to dieting and it has been very
very effective for me as as well number
two the the second strategy here we're
going to get back into some more
conventional uh Fitness and diet related
advice here uh and number two is eat
slow and Savor uh so what we're talking
about here is the speed of eating and
the way you focus while eating so again
this has clear parallels and carryover
to a recent episode about mindful eating
uh in that episode I talked about how
one of the ways mindful eating uh can
make dieting a little bit more tolerable
is because it usually involves paying
attention to your food savoring your
food enjoying your food very thoroughly
and simultaneously eating at a slower
rate and when we eat more slowly
a few things can happen based on the
research that's available so far uh
number one you have a longer time that
you spend interacting with the flavors
and the Aromas of the meal you chew more
you take time between bites you know
you're really savoring this meal and I'm
going to use a completely made up term
here but it is rooted in some findings
the way I frame this is that if you eat
more slowly and you Savor your meal you
experience what I call a greater static
satisfaction quotient so basically the
the sensory satisfaction per calorie
consumed uh it's a completely made up
term of a nonsensical metric but you get
the idea you experience as you're
interacting more with the flavors and
the Aromas and you're savoring the meal
you get more arbitrary units of sensory
satisfaction from enjoying that meal per
calorie consumed in the meal and it
seems like that actually might uh impact
some process is related to memory and
cognition and what I mean by that is
there seems to be some evidence that if
we do Savor a meal very intentionally we
have uh what appears to be kind of a
heightened memory of that satisfying
eating experience and that memory seems
to carry over a bit throughout the
remainder of the day such that if you
have you know this really satisfying
lunch that's kind of burned into your
memory because you really savored it and
took your time with it there is some
evidence to suggest that perhaps you
might uh unintentionally without
thinking about it choose to consume
fewer calories at dinner because of that
prior lunch for example another area
where slow eating rates seem to be
beneficial would be in the realm of
satiety signals so there's this whole
Cascade of events that occurs when we
are eating
um you know our body gets these
physiological signals that we are in
fact eating consuming uh you know a mass
of food with caloric content there are a
number of processes that kind of take
place by which our body starts to
receive the signal okay we're eating now
and eventually we have achieved a
sufficient level of satiety we're
satisfied with the amount we've eaten in
this meal therefore you know this
Cascade of signaling events is going to
occur and our brain is going to get the
message due to satiety hormones and kind
of the downstream effects of those
hormones interacting with their
receptors the brain will get the message
okay we've had enough here it's time to
discontinue the meal and event and at
this point it's time to stop eating
um but though that whole Cascade of
events uh where the satiety hormones are
increasing in circulation making it to
the areas where their receptors are you
know having all these Downstream
cellular effects after you know the
hormone binds to the receptor it takes
time for these satiety signals to kick
in there is a bit of a lag between the
time we're actually consuming and
initiating and continuing the meal and
the time where our brain finally gets
that signal and says okay we've had
enough it's all good and so there is
some research indicating that if we slow
our eating rate intentionally
we can allow more time for that whole
Cascade of events to occur and it's very
likely that we will receive and really
fully interpret that message of high
satiety before we've had an opportunity
to consume a much greater number of
calories at that meal so what we're
doing is giving our satiety hormones in
a way a bit of a head start and we're
saying hey I'm going to let you go ahead
and start conveying this message I'm
going to eat slowly and therefore my
brain is going to really perceive that
we've had enough here before I
unintentionally consume more calories
than I really need based on hunger and
satiety levels so all of these things in
combination can facilitate lower energy
intake and ultimately these are
strategies that can help us navigate
hunger pretty effectively when we are
dieting so like I said so far the two
strategies are adopting an
acceptance-based approach to weight
management specifically as it pertains
to hunger and food cravings number two
eating more slowly and savoring our
meals these are both strategies that can
help us
manage our appetite and hunger while
dieting and make a low calorie diet a
little bit more enjoyable in terms of
adhering to it and not being miserable
throughout the process number three this
is another one that we've talked about
in a recent episode we had an episode
that was all about cardio for weight
loss and I talked a little bit about the
relationship between physical activity
or non-lifting exercise and appetite
regulation and number three here uh the
Third Kind of strategy that we might
utilize to manage hunger while dieting
is to titrate the amount of non-lifting
exercise so what I'm talking about there
is non-exercise physical activity and
structured cardio type exercise now the
relationship between physical activity
and appetite management is a little bit
complicated so as I mentioned in that
previous episode if you're someone who
is very very sedentary at Baseline and
you increase your physical activity
level and become somewhat active so
you're going from extremely sedentary to
kind of active or pretty active when
that occurs there seems to be research
indicating that hunger and appetite
become more tightly coupled to our
energy expenditure so you know when we
think about what dictates uh the amount
of food that we eat
um obviously it seems clear to me based
on the literature that the amount we eat
is not solely dictated by energy
expenditure and energy intake and the
balance between them uh it doesn't seem
to be directly and solely dictated by
hunger and satiety signals necessarily
like physiological needs for energy it
definitely seems that uh you know
certainly behavioral and psychological
elements influence are our total energy
intake and also hedonic aspects of
eating and so when we talk about
physical activity as it pertains to
appetite management
there's one paper that kind of presents
a dichotomy between physiological
determinants of energy intake and more
hedonic determinants of energy intake
and what what we see and the way that
they they put it in the paper is
homeostatic versus non-homeo static
inputs that influence our energy intake
or our appetite so the homeostatic stuff
would be physiological needs for energy
physiological determinants of satiety
levels and then the non-homeostatic
stuff would be things like just hedonic
eating which refers to eating because it
is a pleasant experience and you know we
have reward centers in our brain that
really light up and enjoy it when we eat
things that taste good so there's always
this kind of balance between this
hedonically driven eating and this
homeostatic kind of physiologically
driven eating and the research would
indicate I as I was starting before that
kind of detour when we go from very very
sedentary to kind of active that
increase in physical activity seems to
recouple our appetite regulation to
these homeostatic factors the
physiological factors that actually
dictate our satiety signaling and so
what that means is going from very
sedentary to kind of active in many
cases is going to reduce our
non-homiostatic hedonic eating and it's
going to put us in a place where we are
actually less likely to passively
overeat because of these kind of hedonic
drivers that are more focused on just
seeking out the reward sensation of
eating something that tastes good so
sometimes people will find if they go
from very sedentary to kind of active
their energy intake actually goes down
because they're recoupling their satiety
signaling and their appetite regulation
to their actual energy expenditure
rather than having this massive
influence from not
non-homeostatic hedonic eating so a
little bit of physical activity in a
previously sedentary person seems to
actually
enhance appetite regulation in a way
that would make dieting a little bit
easier and a little bit more tolerable
but
a lot of folks who listen to this
podcast are in a different position a
lot of folks who listen to this podcast
are pretty active and do a pretty good
amount of exercise throughout the week
whether it's physical not exercise
physical activity or structured exercise
and the question is how does exercise
impact appetite in individuals who were
already active at the start so if
someone who's already pretty active
ramps up their physical activity very
aggressively how will that impact
appetite now acutely it's pretty simple
in the acute sense
if we take a really active person and we
put them through a brutal protocol of
high-intensity interval training really
nasty anaerobic high intensity stuff for
a couple hours after that exercise bout
we can safely expect that they are going
to have a temporary transient reduction
in appetite but it'll come back and so
this kind of temporary transient effect
doesn't necessarily tell us over the
course of a week if they're they're
going to eat more or less than they used
to
um and you know we can have some
confidence that in you know the first
hour after exercise they're probably
going to eat less than they otherwise
would but when it comes to you know
broader overall dietary intakes what's
going to happen three hours or four
hours or five hours later are they going
to kind of over compensate and make up
for that appetite suppression that's
kind of a pertinent question in the
literature and when we talk about The
Chronic impact of exercise on appetite
what we really need to consider is to
what extent is compensation happening
right so what I mean by compensation is
if someone ramps up their physical
activity from pretty high to extremely
high they are going to increase their
daily energy expenditure and to some
extent and what that means is we should
expect that you know if their appetite
and satiety regulation is tightly
coupled to their energy expenditure
there should be some um some upward
pressure exerted on their appetite and
hunger response they should be uh you
know in eating at least a little bit
more to make up for the fact that energy
expenditure has gone up or they should
at least feel the urge to eat a little
bit more in order to make up for the
fact that energy expenditure has gone up
but the question is what does that
compensation look like will it be
incomplete complete or over compensation
so for example
if a person who's already pretty active
ramps up their physical activity even
more and becomes extremely active and
let's say they increase their total
daily energy expenditure by as they make
this change just arbitrary number it
goes up by 200 calories a day
if they have in an incomplete
compensatory increase in appetite they
might passively induce an energy deficit
and what I mean by that is if they
increase their expenditure by 200
calories a day but their appetite only
increases enough that they kind of
choose to eat an extra 150 calories a
day there's still a 50 calorie deficit
there because their appetite and hunger
response was not fully compensating you
know or fully matching that increase in
energy expenditure so I would call that
uh just the terminology I like to use as
an incomplete compensatory increase in
hunger so they increased expenditure 200
calories per day but their hunger only
kind of nudged them toward eating an
additional 150 calories a day we might
find in that case that this person is
kind of unintentionally creating an
energy deficit and so in that case
introducing exercise to facilitate their
weight loss goal there's a net benefit
there when we look at it in a vacuum
like that it's some folks might might
experience what we call a complete
compensatory increase in hunger or
appetite such that they're basically
nudged toward energy balance so this
person might increase their energy
expenditure by 200 calories a day and if
they just kind of follow their hunger
cues and eat to the point of comfort
they might find that they naturally are
just eating 200 extra calories a day and
they're totally compensating for that
increase in expenditure and then of
course there is the potential for
overcompensation so perhaps this person
increases energy expenditure by 200
calories a day through added exercise
but maybe their appetite response is
Amplified to an exaggerated extent such
that their their hunger is nudging them
toward eating maybe 300 extra calories
per day so in that case we would see a
scenario where this is kind of backfired
you know if they were hoping that they
were adding cardio to make their weight
loss process a little bit easier or more
tolerable and now they're actually
introducing a situation where their
hunger responds to the exercise is
exaggerated and Amplified relative to
the net benefit of that extra energy
expenditure so they might find that
because of this exaggerated appetite and
hunger response they've actually made
their process a little bit harder and in
terms of managing hunger while dieting
they might have created more of an
uphill battle than had they not
introduced the exercise at all so when
we talk about you know it's pretty
simple for people who are very inactive
at Baseline if they go from Super
sedentary to kind of active when we talk
about managing hunger and appetite we
can expect that to actually have a
beneficial effect when it comes to just
more effectively managing their appetite
while dieting when it comes to someone
who's already pretty active at Baseline
now we have to wonder
is their appetite response going to be
uh incomplete is it going to be complete
or is it going to be essentially an over
compensation where they're driven to eat
uh enough food just based on their
hunger response that would actually put
them in a net Surplus in terms of energy
uh and so which of those three options
seems to be observed in the literature
unfortunately it's pretty complicated
um you know there are a lot of papers in
this area that seem to be very
conflicting
um the question is the conflicting
findings in this area is it a matter of
true inter-individual variation and
responses so is it true that just
different human beings respond to this
physiological thing truly in a different
manner
or are we seeing inconsistent findings
because the methods are different from
study to study and you know what we're
not really certain of is across all
these mixed findings that seem to be
very uh heterogeneous and very
inconsistent are we seeing true
inter-individual variation or are we are
we seeing variation that is driven by
differences in study methods and study
design unfortunately I don't think I'm
ready to give a firm answer on that but
what I can say is based on the
literature when an active person
increases energy expenditure and we're
trying to to figure out what is the net
impact on their appetite is it going to
be so small that you know that they're a
kind of nudged toward a deficit is it
going to be totally exaggerated to the
point that they're actually making uh
their hunger management more challenging
on the diet it seems to just depend uh
from study to study and so my kind of
practical takeaway from looking at that
literature is I'd love to see more of it
I'm interested in seeing uh if we can
start to really parse some of that
variation and figure out what's driving
it but for now my practical
recommendation is to Simply let your
experience guide the way
um and what that means is we can view
this physical activity level
as a modifiable variable that can have
an impact on hunger and appetite so it
could be a lever that we could pull in
order to influence hunger and appetite
management while we're dieting but the
direction seems to vary in terms of how
we actually manipulate this variable and
what I mean by that is there might be
some folks who are doing a dieting phase
they're really struggling with Hunger it
seems to be really getting out of
control there might be some folks where
if you say hey you know what let's just
do a little bit less physical activity
that might actually help them manage
their hunger better for other folks it's
very possible that you could say you
know what it might be beneficial to
actually ramp up some of your physical
activity
um and perhaps that'll allow us to eat
more while maintaining the same net
kogoric deficit for some people having a
higher Reliance on physical activity
when establishing the deficit it
actually actually might help them
navigate and manage their hunger and
appetite better so there are some
situations where if you're struggling
with Hunger perhaps leaning more on
physical activity could be helpful but
for other individuals scaling back
physical activity might be helpful when
it comes to managing hunger so I know
that's kind of a long mini segment that
leads us to a bit of an unsatisfying
conclusion but it's important to
recognize that people do seem to respond
uh in terms of hunger and appetite
people seem to respond to big changes in
physical activity but the direction and
magnitude of that response seems to be
quite variable so it is a thing that can
be manipulated but when it comes to how
you manipulate that you probably want to
let your individual experience guide the
way or if you're coaching someone really
be attentive and listen to that
individual's experience you know ask
them how it's going and really take that
experience Siri obviously and let it
guide the direction for the future
now number four uh something to help
manage hunger and appetite while dieting
would be reducing energy density and
specifically meal level energy density
and as as a side note when we talk about
reducing energy density I like to
encourage people to make the easy swaps
first and I'll explain what that means
in a second but when we talk about
energy density
um you know energy density is a pretty
pretty simple metric what we're talking
about is the calories of a serving of
food uh relative to the mass or volume
in the research it's scaled relative to
mass but you know sometimes people when
we when we think about energy density in
the simplest form a lot of times we just
talk about filling up a pla a plate or
filling up a bowl and saying okay two
bowls they're the same size we're
filling them both with food if we have
low energy density there might only be
200 calories of food in this bowl if
we're going with higher energy density
there might be four times that many
calories within this bowl so the volume
that's being filled is the same they're
covering the same area of the plate for
example but energy density basically
tells us for a given just chunk of food
whether we're measuring it as mass or
volume or area on a plate you know which
of these options has more calories you
know so energy density is the energy
content of food scaled to you know the
mass or the volume of that serving of
food so easy example you know you could
have uh you know a big bowl of
watermelon or a big plated cheesecake
and let's say they weigh exactly the
same if you eat all of it you know I
mean the watermelon is going to be way
lower in calories per gram or per unit
volume than the cheesecake you know so
that that's what we're talking about
with energy density and when we look at
foods with low energy density uh we're
talking about foods that typically have
a lot of water content a lot of fiber
content usually uh you know uh high
fiber vegetables come to mind uh melons
berries you know fruits that have
relatively low calories per serving
weight these are foods with low energy
density and there's a recent paper by
Flynn and colleagues that I'll link in
the show notes we actually did a
research Spotlight about that so so if
you're on the stronger by science email
newsletter you probably already have
heard about this but Flynn and
colleagues were were really interested
in answering or exploring a pretty
simple question
and the question was
what actually signals
when we're done with a meal what what is
the signal that causes us to discontinue
eating when we initiate a meal and they
basically had uh two different ideas you
know one signal that could encourage us
that could encourage us to discontinue a
meal would be the volume of food right
so you could think of eating a giant
bowl of vegetables probably the thing
that's going to make you full is just
the sheer volume of what you're eating
rather than the number of calories that
you have eaten it's very likely that the
volume signal that you're you're
experiencing as your stomach fills up
with with literal matter uh you know
that takes up a high volume of space in
your stomach that is probably what's
going to be the thing dictating when you
stop eating rather than a particular
caloric value that you reach now on the
other hand it does seem like calorie
content is a useful signal you know so
so when you're eating something that is
just very very energy dense if you're
thinking of like a dessert food a very
very rich dessert that is just very
heavy uh you know you're probably not
going to eat a massive massive massive
amount of it because it'll just be so
heavy you know I mean you you can sense
as you're eating something that is just
extremely calorically dense like man I
am really filling up here even though
the actual volume of food is not really
all that much and so what they're
interested in looking at is uh you know
how does energy density predict when we
are going to discontinue a meal or
decide that we have basically had enough
of whatever we're eating and they
created a two component model by which
they
um kind of indicated how energy density
pertains to these two different signals
that can initiate the termination of a
meal and so what they what they decided
was uh you know based on a really
analysis of empirical data the the data
indicated that when energy density for
the entire meal
is very very low volume is the dominant
signal that basically leads us to
discontinue a meal and stop eating
however as the energy density of the
meal starts to increase the actual
caloric intake the calorie content of
the meal takes over as the dominant
signal and so this kind of makes sense
intuitively you know if we get back to
that example a big serving of watermelon
a big serving of Cheesecake were not
necessarily going to eat the same volume
of food if we just eat both to our
hearts content on two separate occasions
it's not necessarily the volume that
always dictates how much we're going to
eat you know we're probably going to eat
more volume of the watermelon than the
cheesecake if we have enough of both
available and we're just told to eat
until we're content but at the same time
it's not like we're just going to keep
eating the water you know we're not
going to eat the same exact calorie
content either
um so we're not going to eat the same
volume of these two different foods nor
are we going to eat the same calorie
content of these two different foods
there's clearly an interplay between the
volume signal and the calorie content
signal and energy density seems to be
the variable that helps us determine uh
when we are going to discontinue a meal
and which of those signals is going to
be the first one to basically step in
and say all right you're done you've had
plenty it's probably time to end the
meal here so it's not just one or the
other it's a convergence of both and the
meal level energy density seems to be
the factor that really dictates uh the
the interplay between those two signals
so
the paper by Flynn and colleagues
basically what they found is there was a
bit of a threshold area
where uh where where the main signal
starts to change so if you're eating a
meal and the energy density of the
entire meal is less than about 1.75
calories per gram
then volume is probably going to be the
key signal that causes you to
discontinue that meal however as you
start eating meals that are more
calorically dense there is a greater
likelihood that the calorie content
signal is going to terminate the meal
before the volume signal kicks in and
again we're talking about
uh energy density for the whole meal
once it starts to get above you know
1.75 to 2.53 I mean the more it starts
climbing up the more that calorie
content becomes the dominant signal and
the actual volume of food that you're
eating becomes a much less noteworthy
um determinant of how much you're
actually going to eat in that meal now
I've said on several occasions I've
really uh reiterated the term meal level
energy density and the reason I say that
is this research does seem to indicate
just based on the theory that it
proposes
the energy density of specific Foods
probably doesn't matter all that much it
really does come down to the average
meal level energy density the reason I
say that is sometimes people will have
this really really energy dense meal and
they'll say you know what maybe I'll
throw a piece of celery on the plate you
know nice low energy density food that
that'll make it so that I fill up with
this stalk of celery and then I'll eat
less of the other stuff
probably not the case unless you're
making a pretty noteworthy shift in the
meal level energy density so for example
if you're sitting down with a meal and
the energy density of this meal is like
three kilocalories per gram if you're
knocking that down from three to two
point eight it probably doesn't matter
at all okay so that probably would not
be an effective way to utilize This
research but if you were able to knock
it down from three all the way down to
one or one point five then you might be
putting yourself in a position where the
volume signal takes over and it causes
you to discontinue that meal before you
eat a much higher uh calorie content so
if we can get the meal level energy
density down below
1.75 or 1.5 kilocalories per gram it
increases the likelihood that we're
going to fill up on volume before we get
into a position to eat way more calories
than we intended but as the energy
density starts getting really really
high for that meal it probably means
that we're we're more like likely to
overeat because that volume signal is
not going to jump in and cut us off
ahead of time now another thing I
mentioned when I was talking about this
concept is making the easy swaps first
so sometimes people say man I mean
changing the energy density of my meal
it means I'm going to have to you know
develop totally different eating
preferences totally different style of
eating maybe Branch out into completely
different Cuisines that are more
conducive to low energy density meals
that's not necessarily the case I mean
one of the biggest swaps I made lately
is
um I I started replacing some of my
white rice that I eat with riced
cauliflower and I know that there's a
whole uh an army of people who are like
please stop replacing everything with
cauliflower uh but honestly I think
cauliflower rice is a pretty good
substitute especially when you consider
the context in which I'm eating it I'm
usually making you know mixing up rice
with some veggies some chickpeas some
teriyaki sauce some soy sauce it's a
really nice kind of stir-fried kind of
dish and honestly if I swapped out the
white rice and I bring in the
cauliflower rice or the rice cauliflower
I should say uh I don't really notice
much of a difference in terms of
enjoyment I know some people are going
to think that's crazy uh but it does
allow me to really meaningfully change
the energy density of that meal with a
very simple swap that doesn't really
require a big change or overhaul when it
comes to my dietary habits and
preferences so when we talk about
reducing energy density two really
important points first of all it's all
about energy density of the meal if
you're just bringing in a tiny bit of
food with low energy density in the
context of a meal that is super high in
energy density that little introduction
of one extra food it's probably not
going to matter all that much
um
so yeah like I said we're talking about
meal level energy density and we really
want to make sure that we are making the
easy swaps first I think that's the most
practical way to apply this particular
strategy
as the first and only Fitness podcast
with a steadfast commitment to
traditional Family Values we know that
protecting families is important right
you are Eric but I will note there are
some things that are even more important
than protecting traditional family
values and the moral fabric of our
society that's right Greg it's important
to protect families but it's even more
important to protect corporate entities
that's why I joined the Advisory board
for the Sports Nutrition Association
Along with trusted Fitness Pros like
Danny Lennon and distrusted arch nemesis
like Eric Helms the Sports Nutrition
Association is the home of Sports
Nutrition they are dedicated to ensuring
the sustainable prosperity of the Sports
Nutrition profession and they offer a
unique Pathway to robust insurance
coverage for your Sports Nutrition
business simply put it's the best way to
protect the corporate entities that are
closest to your heart and I should note
if you're an individual sole proprietor
writer providing Sports nutrition
services and not a corporate entity the
Sports Nutrition Association can help
you out as well that is correct all
insurance plans are handled individually
on a case-by-case basis regardless of
how your Sports Nutrition business is
structured but even if you don't want
insurance coverage sna membership comes
with a bunch of other perks and
advantages the Sports Nutrition
Association is the only Global
professional sports body that has a
defined standard for Sports Nutrition
scope of practice for its members this
ensures that members maintain high
standards in their practice so that the
public can always trust in the quality
associated with the services of an
accredited Sports nutritionist through
the Sports Nutrition Association if you
already meet their minimum education
requirements you can become an
accredited Sports nutritionist today if
you don't meet those education
requirements yet you can enroll in the
certificate program in a applied Sports
Nutrition that allows you to become a
provisionally accredited member upon
completion to learn more about the
Sports Nutrition Association head over
to
www.sportsnutritionassociation.com today
today's episode is sponsored by the
Sports Nutrition Association and
stronger by science LLC sincerely
appreciates their support
now number five another strategy for
managing hunger and appetite during
weight loss or calorie restricted diet
number five is to opt for harder food
textures and this is another one that
has been covered in a research Spotlight
and stronger by science so if you're on
the email list you're probably already
aware of this in that research Spotlight
I covered a study by Teo and colleagues
and what they found was something that's
been found multiple times before which
is that when you eat harder Foods you
tend to passively make the decision to
eat fewer calories in that meal so by
eating harder food textures or more
viscous food textures that require more
chewing more swallowing more savoring
when we eat these harder or more viscous
textures we do tend to passively eat
less without intentionally trying to eat
less and there are a few things at play
here so when you're eating a food that
is harder and texture or more viscous in
many cases it will have more fiber which
can have an effect that promotes satiety
in many cases you're going to have more
mass or volume per calorie consumed in
other words you're probably going to
have a lower energy density you're
probably going to have a slower eating
rate you know if if food is harder or
more viscous you know a lot of times you
have to chew it more or you have to slow
down the rate at which you consume it
once again as an extension of all this
chewing and slowing down you're probably
going to have longer interaction time
with the flavors and the Aromas of that
meal and another thing is that just the
the mouth feel tends to be a little bit
less conducive to passive overeating so
the texture itself is probably a little
bit less conducive to a high level of
snack ability and passive over
consumption of calories so when we look
at the combined impact of eating foods
that are just having a general tendency
toward foods that are harder or more
viscous in terms of their texture we're
probably leveraging that term I
mentioned previously that increased
satisfaction quotient you know we are
having more sensory satisfaction per
calorie consumed because we are slowing
down and savoring just so we don't choke
on it basically uh this can feed into a
heightened memory of that satisfactory
eating experience this can give us a
little more time for our satiety signals
to kick in and ultimately it can
facilitate lower energy intake without
um you know without a whole lot of
planning or intentional effort toward
additional restrictions so this is
another area where some folks if they're
aiming for the same calorie Target and
their dieting and hunger is a common
thing for them they might find that if
they just switch over to some foods with
slightly harder or more viscous textures
they might find that this low calorie
diet becomes a little bit more more
tolerable and helps them manage their
hunger and appetite just a little bit
more effectively number six
number six is minimizing foods that are
hyper palatable and so when we talk
about hyper palatable Foods we're
talking about foods that taste really
really really really kind of unnaturally
good right so some of these foods that
are really designed specifically to hit
all the right notes and be just
incredibly incredibly tasty now I don't
want to make the appeal the nature
fallacy and act like food companies that
make foods that taste great are evil or
that they're doing something wrong food
companies want to make foods that taste
good that's why they're in the food
business is so people will love their
food I don't think that that's a wrong
thing you know I want to go up to a chef
who's very good at cooking and say man
it is it's really a disgrace that you
are making this food taste so good like
you should be ashamed of that obviously
that I mean that's not my perspective so
I don't want to demonize foods that are
hyper palatable because you know people
who are chefs they work very hard to
make their Foods taste excellent uh
people who work in the uh the food food
industry they worked very hard to make
their Foods taste great because they
want consumers to be satisfied but the
problem is when foods are hyper
palatable and really really really good
you know better than we could ever even
imagine yeah encountering
um you know in the hunter-gatherer World
Without You know these um remarkably
complex food combinations when we're
eating these hyper palatable Foods it
can create a pretty significant
challenge when it comes to
enjoying and adhering to a low calorie
diet or just making a low calorie diet
tolerable in the context of weight loss
now the reason these hyper palatable
foods make things more challenging is
because as we're rep regulating uh
appetite and desire to eat the brain is
constantly balancing a number of
different inputs
so when we're trying to manage appetite
hunger desire to eat there are many
different inputs that that get factored
into that so one is just good
old-fashioned hunger and as an extension
of that good old-fashioned you know
physiological satiety signals but the
brain is also considering reward
responses so our hunger centers our
satiety centers our reward centers in
the brain are doing this delicate dance
with one another to try to coordinate
our decisions pertaining to uh what we
eat you know coordinating our appetite
and our desire to eat so when we're
dieting we have in many cases we'll have
periods where hunger is high where
satiety is low but also where our reward
centers in our brain seem to be hyper
responsive to really palatable Foods so
it's not just that hyper palatable foods
have extra calories in them it's that
when we're dieting and restricting
calories we actually do have we appear
to have an exaggerated uh
neurophysiological response to the
intake of hyperpalatable foods and so
what we see is when we uh when we
combine these factors of increased
hunger reduce
satiety and Amplified reward response to
food in the brain and then we introduce
a hyper palatable food in many cases
that is going to be a recipe for
overeating and more more specifically
unintentional overeating that causes us
to deviate from our goals or you know
sometimes it doesn't cause us to deviate
from our goals but it just makes
adhering to our our dietary uh plan way
harder than it needs to be so this comes
up a lot in you know in the natural
bodybuilding world
there's a lot of folks who got into you
know the If It Fits your Macros flexible
dieting style of dieting and it works
you know if you're hitting your Targets
on a daily basis you're going to get in
shape it's been proven time and time
again not really controversial to say
that however uh I have encountered
uh bodybuilders and physique athletes
who take this approach and they engage
in a style of eating that is uh
it it's really not doing them any favors
and what I mean by that is they will say
okay today my calorie goal is 2200
calories
I am going to navigate you know navigate
this calorie Target and construct my
diet today in a way that maximizes hyper
palatability at the expense of all other
considerations and so what I mean by
that is you know instead of having you
know a piece of chicken some veggies
maybe a little sweet potato maybe just a
little bit of something for dessert the
meal just becomes like yeah I made this
like chocolate peanut butter protein
pudding and I've got this low calorie
ice cream and I'm going to throw a
Pop-Tart in there and some low calorie
cupcakes that I made all of a sudden
it's like every element of the meal is a
dessert food that is designed to be as
palatable as you could possibly get
using low calorie Alternatives and
things like that now none of those
things in a vacuum is necessarily
unfavorable or deleterious or bad in any
way but when you are designing the
entirety of your diet to maximize hyper
palatability on a low calorie diet your
probably not doing yourself a lot of
favors and in fact what I found over the
years is when people do that they're
more likely to deviate from their diet
because all of this hyper palatability
is is really just overriding their
ability to just terminate the meal and
stop eating when it's time to stop
eating
um so so I've seen that people either
will overeat because of that or they
will adhere to their diet and and adhere
to their macro targets and calorie
targets but the process is very painful
I mean they get to the point where they
construct these meals
that are hyper palatable but it's not
helping them reduce their hunger or
increase their satiety very much the
hyper palatability is off the charts so
even when they are able to terminate
that meal at the right time it is just
devastating when they have to finally
put the spoon down and say okay no more
servings of these you know low calorie
protein cupcakes that I've been you know
you know going to town on
um so I noticed that people uh they just
make it way harder to stick to their
diet because in a weird way they've kind
of made their diet too tasty to be
effective for what they're trying to do
and I know that sounds really silly but
when we are on a calorie restricted diet
we can use palatability as a modifiable
variable to set us up for success and
what I mean by that is we want our meals
to be palatable enough to be enjoyable
but not so palatable that the end of the
meal is a tragic event where we say oh I
can't believe I have to stop eating that
stuff was so incredible so what we want
to try to do here when we're
constructing a diet you know not the
targets for the diet we've got the
targets when we're starting to to
construct actual meals and figure out
what actual foods are going into this we
want to make sure that we're not just
thinking about what is how could I make
this as hyper palatable as possible
given the constraints of my calorie
Target what we want to think about is
how can I make this good enough to be
enjoyable but not so good that it's
going to be tragic when I have to stop
eating this meal and how can I use food
choices that are going to be com not
just conducive to promoting palatability
but also conducive to promoting uh you
know fullness satiety reducing hunger
things of that nature so before you get
on a diet and say how am I going to make
the um
the perfect low-calorie high protein
cake and ice cream meal think about and
I'm not saying that any of those foods
are bad you know I don't want to make it
seem like I'm saying you know because
hyper palatable Foods tend to be you
know kind of a modern invention due to
the you know appeal of the nature
fallacy that makes them bad that's not
the case that's not what I believe uh
I'm not saying there's anything wrong
with any of these hyper palatable Foods
in isolation but I am saying if you're
on a calorie restricted diet and you're
struggling with hunger and appetite
management introducing more hyper
palatable Foods even if they fit your
Macros is probably not the best strategy
for you and in fact you might want to
work the other direction and say how can
I have a satisfying diet that is perhaps
a little bit less palatable uh in a way
that's going to help me uh really stick
to my dietary goals effectively now
number seven here the seventh strategy
um this this is gonna uh again pertain a
bit to food selection so you know we've
talked a little bit about uh food
selection in terms of energy density
food texture uh palatability
number seven here is to the the general
idea is to end a meal strategically and
this uh is a funny little uh tip that
I've picked up over the years it's one
of the few instances where I noticed
something very very strongly anecdotally
in my personal experience and then I
said
that seems weird that this seems like
such a strong and repeatable effect that
I'm observing is there research to
support this and the research was so on
the nose I really was like I okay like
it was one of those magic situations
where my lived experience was just
perfectly reflective of the research out
there and I simply didn't know the
research existed beforehand
um and so perhaps I'm just you know
committing an act of confirmation bias
there but the background here
is that I noticed when I was a
competitive bodybuilder you know
prepping really hard uh satiety was hard
to come by but I noticed that when I was
eating really really spicy meals I had a
lower desire to eat after that meal it
was helping me really uh reduce my
likelihood of wanting to seek out more
food when the meal was done so spicy
meals were having that effect for me and
I was just dumping uh cayenne pepper and
black pepper on all my meals and making
them really really spicy hot sauces all
that stuff and the reason I did that was
simple I mean when you get to a really
low calorie diet a lot of the condiments
and sauces that you would typically use
you know they start to be just too
calorically dense you can't really spare
the calories for those sauces and
condiments so I got to the point where I
was using very low calorie spicy hot
sauces and then just getting straight to
the the spices themselves so I noticed
that spicy meals were helping me uh
reduce my desire to eat I also noticed
that when I was drinking more green tea
either between meals or directly after a
meal I was also noticing a lower desire
to eat so I looked into the research
eventually because I was like this is
crazy this is a really repeatable effect
that I'm observing and I found the
research that was just completely on the
nose so one example was a paper by
reinbach and colleagues which I'm going
to link in the show notes here but they
specifically looked at capsaicin and
green tea so capsaicin you know is a a
component of spicy peppers that really
gives them their kick and then of course
you know green tea was the other thing
they looked at and they found that
capsaicin and green tea
suppressed hunger and increased satiety
particularly in the context of an energy
deficit and so that paper was looking at
hunger and satiety but I also suspect
that
desire to eat plays a pretty big role
beyond the impact of hunger and satiety
and I know it sometimes it's tempting to
wrap those things together but there are
some differences between hunger and
satiety and something like desire to eat
and desire to eat is exactly what it
sounds like
um you know there are some situations
where you could be slightly hungry but
still have no desire to eat so desire to
eat isn't just hunger and satiety it
also brings in elements of things like
appetite and hedonic elements of seeking
out and eating experience and so with
desire to eat
um you know I think that the easy
easiest example is my experience with
green tea so if I think about green tea
and this is of course an opinion this is
totally subjective
but when I think about you know what
food that I eat on a regular basis goes
really well with green tea the answer is
nothing uh for me based on my flavor
preferences if I'm drinking plain green
tea there's really not a food that I
want to pair with it I enjoy the green
tea but it kind of just kills my desire
to eat anything else just by nature of
the flavor it has now in if we look at a
different example if I think about what
goes well with coffee oh well uh you
know a pastry a cookie ice cream a nice
uh you know creamy cocktail beverage I
mean literally everything goes with
coffee I get I could eat almost anything
and say yeah coffee made that better and
that made my coffee better you know so
um I think in a very simple way if we
introduce some of these foods that lower
our desire to eat based on our personal
experience it can help us end meals when
the meals are done and so that is
something that I noticed and then after
no noticing it repeatedly started to
implement strategically if I was having
a meal and getting toward the end of it
I was like I feel like at the end of
this meal I'm going to want to eat more
and I'd like to proactively get ahead of
that desire to eat I'll start uh you
know uh I'll put the kettle on get the
water going and say when I finish this
serving of food I'm going to have a cup
of green tea and then I'll reassess and
see if I feel different after and almost
always I feel very differently after a
cup of green tea I say actually you know
what I am pretty satisfied I don't think
I want to deviate from my plan and have
a second or a third portion of whatever
I was eating uh now number eight the
final one I want to cover here is a very
simple and it's just eat enough fiber
and eat enough protein and I'm not going
to spend a lot of time on these because
this is very straightforward and most
people who are listening to the stronger
by science podcast are already eating
enough fiber and eating enough Pro 13.
uh just a few uh things I want to point
out first of all
if you are eating a diet that is high in
fiber and high in protein there is a
good chance that you're eating a diet
that has relatively low energy density
and that you're eating a diet that has a
lot of foods that are
um you know like I said low energy
density but also you know potentially
some harder textures
um you know perhaps you know not using a
lot of foods that are super hyper
palatable like Ultra processed foods you
know if you're incorporating a lot of
protein and a lot of fiber into the diet
and it you know a lot of lifters who are
eating a high fiber high protein diet
you're going to see a lot of vegetables
fruits lean meat sources you're going to
see a lot of relatively unprocessed uh
cereals and grain products or you know
cereal and grain products that just have
a relatively low level of processing so
when we talk about eating enough protein
and fiber there isn't interplay with
some of the previous strategies I
mentioned with things like energy
density food texture palatability and
things like that of course there are
many exceptions to these links that I'm
drawing I mean you you could create a
remarkably hyper palatable uh meal plan
that has plenty of fiber and protein you
could create a meal plan with plenty of
fiber and protein that if you really go
out of your way could still have very
few very few foods with low energy
density or very few foods with hard or
very viscous texture so I'm not saying
that this is a universal rule but if
we're looking at correlates of you know
what would this diet look like there
probably are some links between getting
enough fiber and protein and kind of
checking some of the boxes I've already
mentioned a couple things I want to
mention though
number one not all fibers and and not
all proteins have the same effect so
different fiber sources and different
protein sources are going to differ in
terms of really key characteristics such
as their viscosity their texture their
palatability and things of that nature
so it's important to recognize that you
know this is a very simplistic uh tip
which is to get plenty of fiber and
plenty of protein but drinking a lot of
delicious chocolate protein shakes is
not the same thing as eating a lot of
very Bland uh poorly prepared chicken
breasts that taste terrible one of those
is going to have a bigger impact on
desire to eat and hunger management than
the other they differ in many ways the
same is true with fibers not all fibers
impact
hunger satiety appetite regulation the
same way they can vary quite
considerably in terms of their physical
characteristics and viscosity and so
these are General heuristics or general
tips but not all fiber sources and
protein sources are going to have the
same impact when it comes to regulating
hunger and appetite
when it comes to you know fiber's impact
uh it's worth noting that some of its
impact on uh you know a portion of its
impact on hunger and satiety could be
related to the fact that high fiber
foods tend to have low energy density
and they do tend to involve more chewing
and by extension slower eating rates so
I I would entertain the idea sometimes
people push back and they say well the
the research on fiber
as it pertains to hunger and satiety
management you know it could be
confounded by the fact that the high
fiber options that seem to help with
Hunger regulation they tend to be in
studies where they also have lower
energy density harder or more viscous
textures they are eaten more slowly they
have more chewing there is a good
argument to make that some of what we're
attributing to fiber might actually have
more to do with it the energy density of
the food that contains the fiber or uh
the way you know the physical
characteristics of that food product so
that is a caveat that I do think is is
worth mentioning
um nonetheless I I think it the
Practical recommendation still ends up
being hey try to go out and incorporate
some Whole Food
things into your diet that tend to have
fiber so bring in some fibrous
vegetables some fibrous fruits some
fibrous grain products that are you know
some to some extent minimally process
processed that that should probably be
pretty helpful when you're on a calorie
restricted diet another caveat I want to
bring up here pertains to protein so
there's a really interesting study that
I reviewed
back in the day for the mass research
review is at least a couple years ago
now and they were looking it was a
meta-analysis on the impact of protein
on hunger and satiety levels and one of
the observations that was very
interesting was that the impact you know
the study did fire the meta-analysis did
report and find that protein generally
had a favorable effect in terms of
increasing satiety reducing hunger
uh however they did see some indication
in the data that perhaps
protein's impact might wear off over
time we might basically adapt if if we
do a bump in protein intake as a
strategic method
to try to enhance hunger and satiety
regulation
it is possible that we will observe an
initial benefit but then adapt to it and
that benefit will wear off will wear off
either partially or completely over time
and so what that would mean if if future
research bears that out it would mean
that practically speaking you can only
pull that lever so many times because
ultimately you know you're trying to do
this because you're on a low calorie
diet and you're trying to navigate
hunger related challenges so if you just
keep bumping your protein again and
again and again eventually your calorie
intake is going to get so high that
you're not really on a low calorie diet
anymore and so that that's going to
ultimately defeat the purpose of using
protein for this particular outcome so
what that means is uh protein we can
probably use that when we're really in a
pinch to try to get a nice little boost
in satiety and help navigate hunger a
little bit but we might adapt to it and
there's only so many times we can pull
that lever during a dieting phase so
when I'm working with someone who is uh
really digging into a very arduous
dieting phase I do hesitate a little bit
I mean we're all we're typically going
to be on a high protein diet anyway in
order to support uh the growth or
maintenance of muscle mass and fat free
Mass there will be instances where I
strategically will bump protein to help
out a little bit with satiety but those
changes are few and far between and they
have to be done very strategically
because you can't just do it over and
over and over you will reach a practical
limit at which you can no longer justify
bumping protein because you're either
going to have to
really critically displace carbohydrate
and fat from the diet or you're going to
have to let the calorie Target get so
high that we're not really on a low
calorie diet anymore and it defeats the
purpose so wrapping up here
in summary if we are trying to
facilitate hunger and appetite
management during weight loss or doing
or during a calorie restricted diet
there are eight tips that I think can be
helpful number one adopt an acceptance
based approach to Weight Management
number two eat slow and Savor your food
number three uh adjust and titrate your
amount of non-lifting exercise and
physical activity number four reduce
meal level energy density and make the
easy swaps first number five when
possible opt for harder food textures
number six when possible again minimize
foods that are hyper palatable or
minimize their role in your diet uh
number seven end the meal strategically
with a food that disincentivizes you
from continuing the meal further and
then number eight titrate your fiber and
your protein intake strategically now
that leads me to a very valid question
what do we do if we're bulking and
I do want to mention I I wrote a pretty
long article with a lot of different
tips for bulking so I if you are bulking
up and looking for some guidance there I
would encourage you to check out that
article I'm going to link it in the show
notes it's at strongerbyscience.com
bulking but if you're bulking and you're
worried about how do I deal with a
suppressed appetite which is very very
common there are a lot of folks who
they've been bulking up for a while and
if you talk to them they say I'm sick of
it I can't do it anymore I am so full
all the time the thought of eating makes
me feel sick to my stomach appetite
suppression is a real challenge
sometimes with bulking and what's really
convenient is we don't really have to do
too much here uh to to recover a bunch
of ground because when it comes to
strategically navigating appetite
suppression during a bulk or a weight
gain phase
what we're going to do is we're going to
take all those tips for weight loss
phases and just invert them and they end
up being pretty good guidance pretty
good advice for navigating a suppressed
appetite while bulking so for example
number one was adopt an acceptance based
approach in this case instead of
reframing our relationship to hunger or
food cravings we want to reframe our
relationship to fullness and lack of
appetite so we're still reframing we're
still viewing it the same way uh you
know that that River metaphor with the
leaves floating by is still pertinent
here but we are looking at it from a
very very different perspective number
two uh you know my uh the weight loss
approach is to eat slow and Savor we can
flip that around and say well perhaps if
you do a little bit of distracted eating
a little bit of mindless snacking
throughout the day perhaps that'll be a
helpful way for you to get to get extra
calories in uh you know without feeling
uh a really exaggerated response in
terms of appetite suppression from that
calorie intake so perhaps we can use
distracted eating and Mindless snacking
to our advantage when we're trying to
bulk up uh number three titrate your
amount of non-lifting exercise and
physical activity that still applies
because like I said the directionality
of that relationship can be a little bit
unpredictable so there are some folks
who are uh exercising they're bulking
and they notice that they're struggling
with a suppressed appetite sometimes
folks will reduce their physical
activity and it'll help out quite a lot
other folks they'll actually exercise a
little bit more and it'll help them tap
into a bigger appetite so a lot of
variability there but still a variable
that we can manipulate uh you know to
our advantage while bulking you just
have to do it in a very individualized
way and figure out how you personally
respond to changes in physical activity
level number four was to reduce meal
level energy density and to make the
easy swaps first in this case we we
could facilitate bulking by increasing
meal level energy density and the the
thing I always say here is sometimes it
feels wrong you know so there are a lot
of folks who
you know uh are bulking up and
struggling they say I just can't gain
weight and if you give them some little
simple recommendations like hey have you
tried having a candy bar at the end of
your meal and they're like well but if I
eat candy I'm gonna get fat and say well
no you're not like all we're trying to
do here is supplement your diet with
calories if we do that with broccoli
instead of candy bars it's going to be a
lot harder I promise it's going to be
hard to eat a 4 000 calorie 5 000
calorie a day diet if you're doing
chicken breast and broccoli right so
I'll encourage people do the easy
additions first when we're trying to
bump up energy density of course the
first thing would be to unravel any
swaps you made previously so if I were
trying to bulk up I would get rid of the
riced cauliflower and put some white
rice back in the mix that's a pretty
easy swap in the other direction but
yeah increase meal level energy density
even if the choices feel wrong because
all we're trying to do there is
supplement the diet with calories and
frankly uh probably doesn't matter where
they're coming from if your ball talking
you're probably you probably have your
bases covered you're probably getting
enough fiber enough micronutrients you
know we're not really worried that if
you add in a candy bar it's going to
displace critical nutrients that you
need to be healthy most likely scenario
is you're eating more than enough of
just about everything and we're just
trying to get more calories in there
another one that people say you know is
makes them really uh people are really
taken aback when you say like hey have
you considered just sipping on a cup of
work beverage throughout the day you
know something like a fruit juice or
even a even a soft drink you know a
Coca-Cola whatever you need we just need
to get some calories in here sip on a
sports beverage if you need to uh you
know a lot of times people will kind of
balk at that particular recommendation
but uh you know it's not my my typical
General Health advice is not to sip on
sugary you know sweetened beverages all
day but nonetheless there is a time and
a place where it might make sense to do
that uh number five was op opting for
harder food textures if bulking we want
to do the opposite you know we want to
incorporate softer textures things that
have a higher level of processing which
usually creates a better mouth feel
enables a faster eating rate and
generally encourages more passive
increases in caloric consumption so we
want to take that harder food
recommendation completely flip it on its
head and say let's go for softer food
textures let's go for food textures that
are less viscous and that can be
advantageous number six was minimize
foods that are hyper palatable the
reality is hyper palatable foods make it
easier to over consume calories or I
should say to consume more calories if
you're on a weight loss diet that's not
good if you're trying to gain weight and
struggling that's excellent because what
we can do is
you know when we're bulking up an
appetite is suppressed hunger levels are
very low satiety levels are very high
what we would like to do is try to find
a way to
partially override the hunger and
satiety component of uh food intake
regulation we want to really stimulate
those reward centers in the brain so
that we can kind of power through and
say you know I'm not really hungry but
man this tastes great so I'm going to go
ahead and keep on eating anyway so we
can actually ramp up the palatability of
the food we're eating when bulking in a
way that can be strategically
advantageous uh number seven was ending
the meal strategically and specifically
ending a meal with foods that
disincentivize further caloric intake if
we're bulking up we can do the opposite
you know so we want to
um you know avoid foods that
disincentivize further consumption at
the end of the meal so like I said if I
were cutting at the end of a meal I
might have a cup of green tea because to
me that just kind of kills my desire to
eat if I were bulking maybe I would say
you know what I'm going to have a cup of
coffee and a lovely pastry that goes
with that coffee or piece of cake or
some ice cream you know so you want to
think about avoiding the foods that kind
of blunt your appetite at the end of a
meal or between meals and you want to
think about complimentary food pairings
that might actually boost your intake
without making it feel like eating more
is a burden or a chore you want to make
it a really pleasant experience to end
your meal with something that actually
allows you to get some extra calories in
there before the meal is over and then
number eight is titrating fiber and
protein strategically there have been
some scenarios
where I've seen individuals who
strategically aim for the lower end of
the advisable fiber intake range and
they also strategically aim for the
lower end of the advisable protein
intake range and they do that
specifically while bulking so that it's
just a little bit easier to get in more
calories from hyper palatable foods that
have plenty of fat plenty of
carbohydrate things like that so it's
not that they're going on a super low
protein diet if we're bulking up that's
not what we want to do but like I said
it's just about titrating fiber and
protein to find the right balance where
you're supporting hypertrophy very
effectively you're eating enough fiber
to support your overall health and
wellness but you are not eating so much
protein and fiber that it is becoming
difficult to get to your daily calorie
Target
uh so I want to wrap up things here with
a quick uh summary of the episode
we all know that having appropriate
macro and calorie targets is imperative
for weight management but that is just
the beginning by focusing on how we eat
a meal and how we select specific Foods
we have an opportunity to strategically
manage hunger satiety and appetite in
order to support our desired body
composition goal so factors like eating
speed energy density food texture and
palatability are important in addition
to some other extraneous factors like
physical activity levels and
psychological perspectives pertaining to
food intake we can strategically
leverage all these factors to support
successful dieting whether we are
cutting bulking or maintaining
now before I end this episode I hope you
will afford me once again the
opportunity to make a Shameless sales
pitch for macro factor which is the diet
app that Greg and I co-developed along
with a very talented team of colleagues
as you consider the wide variety of diet
approaches and strategies that you might
Implement in the New Year rest assured
that macro Factor can facilitate
whatever you're planning to do first and
foremost it's a remarkably fast
efficient and Convenient Food logger
it's got a huge verified database of
foods and it's got very easy workflows
that you you can add custom Foods custom
recipes and even share your recipes with
friends and family so whatever your food
Choice preferences are macro Factor can
handle it macro Factor has a lot of
flexibility a lot of different uh
coached macro programs that you can
choose from ranging all the way from
low-fat diets to ketogenic diets you can
even Branch out or I should say within
the coaching programs you know you can
choose your your macro distribution
preferences you can also choose four
different protein settings which ties
into what we talked about in today's
episode of kind of strategically
adjusting protein based on what you're
trying to achieve so you can navigate uh
different challenges pertaining to
hunger and appetite regulation so the
coach programs offer a great deal of
flexibility but if you want you can even
use collaborative mode or a manual
program to provide even more flexibility
so in short macro factor is your diet
sidekick it provides all the guidance
support and analytics you need without
infringing
on your ability to make your own
decisions and chart your own course
toward your fitness goals so to learn
more check out macro factorapp.com or
you can just look for it in the app
stores
all right as always thanks for joining
me for another episode of The Stronger
by science podcast we will be back soon
with another
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast if you enjoyed the
podcast be sure to sign up for our free
newsletter to get concise breakdowns of
relevant research as well as 28 free
training programs for all skill levels
and all schedules we hate spam just as
much as you do so we'll only email you
when we have something really
interesting to share with you
you can sign up for the free newsletter
at strongerbyscience.com newsletter or
just go to the stronger by science
homepage and click the free programs
button at the top
if you want to join in on the stronger
by science podcast conversation be sure
to check out our Facebook group and our
subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits be sure to
check with a qualified health care
professional once again thank you for
listening and we will be back soon with
another episode of The Stronger by
science podcast
foreign
[Music]